las regiones del bío bío y la araucanía
en el sur de chile fueron testigos del
regreso de las patrullas de militares la
zona es el escenario desde hace décadas
de un conflicto por las tierras
ancestrales de la comunidad mapuche que
respondieron con una marcha en favor de
los que consideran como sus presos
políticos que pasó hoy día del estado
excepción del estado de que el gobierno
haya cedido de alguna forma a la presión
política a la presión económica al
capital dentro de la zona y los
representantes mapuches se dijeron
abiertos a mantener el diálogo con el
gobierno de gabriel boric los pueblos
originarios rechazan la explotación de
tierras consideradas ancestrales por
parte de empresas agrícolas aquí se está
hablando de los procesos de autonómico
mapuche en donde tendría que haber parte
bien responsable políticamente viendo un
diálogo un diálogo de alto nivel
político donde que tengan que también
quizás y por qué no decirlo que tenga
que tenga que haber peor internacional
es viendo y
tratando del proceso de diálogo del
estado chino con el pueblo gabriel boric
inicialmente en contra de la
remilitarización de la zona volvió a la
política iniciada bajo al ex presidente
piñera y argumentó la decisión en un
supuesto aumento de actos violentos
como estado tenemos una deuda histórica
con los pueblos indígenas y hoy damos un
paso para reconstruir confianza bajo el
marco del respeto junto a con nadie ian
bellas morales y consejeros anunciamos
que duplicaremos presupuesto de compra
de tierras avanzamos en conjunto el
pueblo mapuche lamenta lo que considera
los mismos errores